When it comes to beings with fearsome reputations,
there are few SCPs that are as widely dreaded
as the hard-to-destroy reptile SCP-682.
No sane mortal would ever choose to face such
a creature, and its overwhelming ferocity
and strength have even given the reincarnating
warrior SCP-076-2 Abel pause on more than
one occasion.
But then again, the sane aren’t exactly
in high demand at the SCP Foundation or at
equivalent organizations formed for the purpose
of battling anomalous and supernatural entities.
Organizations such as the Public Safety Devil
Hunters from the popular Manga and Anime Chainsaw
Man count numerous peculiar individuals among
their ranks, and sometimes the best of the
best are marked by a distinctive tendency
for out-of-the-box thinking.
That’s putting it politely, at least.
But this isn’t the story of some aberrant
loser freakazoid - no, definitely not.
The heroine of this tale is none other than
the mightiest and most charismatic future
nobel prize winner ever to grace the rest
of us shameful worms with her presence.
The invincible and dearly beloved blood fiend
Power!
Who just so happens to be the undisputed best
character in Chainsaw Man and all of fiction
as well.
It appeared to be an unusually boring day
at Public Safety, and for this, Kobeni was
grateful.
The young woman had come to expect the absolute
worst from her job as a devil hunter - as
her assignments usually entailed facing down
hellish entities born from the very fears
of the human race.
While one would think that someone who worked
so diligently in the field would have grown
numb to it all, Kobeni still very much retained
her anxieties: both on and off the job.
At least all she had to do today was file
paperwork from one of Public Safety’s like-minded
partners in supernatural management: The SCP
Foundation.
It was a safe and harmless task, aside from
the risk of paper cuts and the associated
potential for the Paper Cut Devil to show
up.
Even so, Kobeni would do her best to make
this rare moment of peace last as long as
possible.
“Witness me, fools!
For I am the great Power!”
A voice cried from down the hallway.
Oh no, not her.
Kobeni thought.
Why is she even at work today?
She’s a fighter for division four, and she’s
not good at anything else.
Loud, exaggerated footsteps rang out through
the hallway as the blood fiend stomped through
the offices of public safety.
Kobeni wanted to shrink until she vanished
from sight or let herself sink into the floor.
Her desire to not have to see Power today
was so great that she contemplated opening
a window and climbing down to the side of
the building to the ground floor.
Please don’t come this way.
Kobeni was still carrying a heavy stack of
freshly filed paperwork, and she didn’t
want her tireless efforts at organization
to go to waste.
She looked frantically at the cabinets in
the storage room she was in, hoping to find
enough space for her to crawl into and make
herself scarce.
But it was too late!
Power slammed open the door of the storage
room and announced her presence.
The shock was so great that Kobeni screamed
and flung the stack of SCP Foundation papers
all over the ground.
She clutched her fast-beating heart, unable
to attend to the mess immediately.
Kobeni hadn’t had to experience a fright
that sudden since the time that she was sent
to hunt the Jump Scare Devil.
The poor girl could never have a surprise
party thrown in her honor again.
True to her nature, Power immediately reprimanded
Kobeni for dropping the papers - stating that
her workmanship was sloppy and that Power
herself could easily carry ten times the amount
of paper.
Kobeni tried not to let the chiding of her
co-worker affect her mood.
She scoped down and began up the papers, but
much to her chagrin: Power decided to help
with this task as well.
The blood fiend began grabbing the papers
and stacking them as assertively as possible
on the nearest surfaces, resulting in many
crumbled edges and uneven piles.
Kobeni attempted, albeit hesitantly, to correct
Power’s people collection method, only to
be met with more scorn.
“You don’t know how to stack paper like
me!”
Power laughed.
“And that’s why I’ll be a millionaire
someday, and you’ll still be here.”
Kobeni nearly cried.
This was just too much for her to handle,
especially on what was supposed to be a calm
day.
That was when Power picked up one the files
and began to read.
It was a record of the infamous cross-test
between SCP-682 and SCP-076-2.
Since Public Safety had previously assisted
the Foundation in re-containing SCP-076-2,
there had been an agreement to send copies
of all relevant documents involving Abel over
to Japan in case of another incident.
As Power struggled through the scientific
language and specifics, she began to envision
her own version of the events that played
out on the page.
She imagined herself as Abel, facing off in
pitched combat against SCP-682 and giving
the terrible lizard a run for its money in
the process.
In the mere seconds it took for Power to finish
reading the document, she had not only concocted
an entire epic battle in mind - but was not
fully convinced that her fantasy was indistinguishable
from one of her own lived experiences.
In her head, Power had definitely fought against
SCP-682.
And she’d do it again in a heartbeat: just
to teach that overgrown reptile another lesson.
Power asked Kobeni if she had ever told her
about the time that the blood fiend had totally
defeated SCP-682.
Kobeni, still clinging to her increasingly
frail understanding of reality, responded
with confusion.
What was she talking about?
Nobody in Public Safety had fought against
an SCP other than 076-2.
There was no possible way that Power was telling
the truth, but the scariest part was: Power
herself didn’t even know that she was lying.
The blood fiend began to relate the sordid
details of her pulse-pounding fight with SCP-682
to Kobeni in great detail.
Kobeni, for her part, was too emotionally
drained at this point to try and stop her.
“So begins the greatest tale ever told,
mortal!”
Power began.
It all started at the bowling alley, where
Power was hanging out with her much less intelligent
friends: Aki and Denji.
The blood fiend had just finished winning
her fifth perfectly scored game in a row when
some shady characters a few lanes over decided
to cause some trouble.
The leader of this little gang was none other
than SCP-682.
“The way you bowl is disgusting!”
The troublemaking lizard said.
This wicked remark would not be stood for!
Not in the proud bowling establishment that
Power had founded with her own money and had
achieved several years of successful business
running herself!
The bowling alley was a pillar of the community,
and she was the owner.
There would be no further disrespect on her
watch.
Power put up her dukes and got ready to bring
the pain down on SCP-682.
Aki and Denji were too terrified to help her
out as usual, but they did their best to cheer
their leader on from the sidelines.
“Stand back, weaklings!
The mighty Power has got this!”
SCP-682 also dismissed its minions and crawled
forward like the big ugly lizard that it was.
It obviously didn’t know better, which is
why it wasn’t backing down in the face of
the greatest devil hunter that the world had
ever known.
Either way, this would be a brawl for the
ages.
Rather than cause damage to her beloved place
of business, Power suggested that she and
her opponent took this fight outside.
Despite its uncouth demeanor, the reptile
had a healthy appreciation for the fine sport
of bowling and, most especially, this particular
excellently run five-star bowling alley.
It agreed to step outside in the interest
of not bringing bowling into this intensely
personal grudge match.
But then again – wasn’t the fight about
bowling?
Power and SCP-682 walked outside the bowling
alley into a vast, trackless wasteland: the
perfect place for both of them to go all out
without hurting any civilians.
Using her ability to control and reshape her
own blood, Power constructed an enormous crimson
mallet that she was able to wield gracefully
in both her hands despite its incredible size.
SCP-682 readied itself.
It had faced many different kinds of humanoid
weapon wielders before, including Abel, but
it was too clever of an adversary to let its
guard down.
Especially because, in this case, the blood
fiend it was fighting was a remarkable businesswoman
and an olympic gold medalist in everything.
The reptile certainly let its guard down.
Power held the hammer above her head and jumped
high into the air.
If she wanted to, she could have circled the
globe in a single leap, but out of respect
for the fact that SCP-682 was a paying customer
at her establishment - she decided to hold
back for the first attack at least.
Nonetheless, she brought the hammer down on
the hard-to-destroy reptile with supreme force.
SCP-682 was smashed into the ground with such
force that a crater opened up beneath its
body.
The reptile itself didn’t seem especially
damaged, but the effects on the surrounding
environment were certainly dramatic and fitting
for an ultimate showdown.
SCP-682 shook off the blow and pounced on
Power with such sudden ferocity that even
she couldn’t remain on her feet.
She tumbled back through the dust and debris
of the wasteland for several miles before
catching himself and standing back up.
Remarkably, there wasn’t even a scratch
on her.
She pointed and laughed at SCP-682, mocking
it for its weakness and stupidity.
“You’ll have to do better than that, Lizard
Devil.” Power said.
The reptile grinned wickedly and responded
with a mocking laugh of its own.
The creature had intentionally taken a hit
from a Power in order to better understand
her fighting moves.
Who wouldn’t want to steal those masterful
techniques, after all?
They’re just too good to resist making a
cheap copy of, and from what Power could remember
from her speed read of the file: that appeared
to be SCP-682’s whole thing.
Soon, a barding of blood-red armor appeared
around SCP-682’s body.
In the short time that it had been fighting
Power, it had clearly learned how to manipulate
its own blood and was now even stronger for
it.
“Hahaha, now I’m as strong as you!
I can’t lose!”
SCP-682 barked at Power.
But she was quick to respond: “Annoying
lizard!
I was already as strong as me before this
fight even began!
Now let’s end this!
For bowling!”
She swung her mallet in a show of force.
The two combatants, now both wielding the
near-limitless powers of the Blood Fiend,
charged at each other across the battlefield.
This was not just a mere sparring match anymore:
it was a fight for the fate of the entire
world.
Snapping back to reality, Power’s retelling
of the story had devolved into a series of
random exclamations and sound effects.
Kobeni was now finding the events incredibly
hard to follow, but thankfully she had been
able to use Power’s highly distractible
mannerisms to finish restacking the files
from the foundation.
Not a minute too soon either, as both she
and Power’s boss, Makima, stepped into the
storage room.
Apparently, Makima was in the process of doing
a headcount of all employees who had come
into work today as any normal and benevolent
superior would.
She had been looking for Kobeni and Power
for some time now and was surprised to find
them here, of all places.
Kobeni explained that she had been putting
away the last of the SCP Foundation files
and would gladly accept whatever new post
she was given.
But Power wasn’t done with her current SCP-682
fascination and turned to Makima, hoping to
be encouraged to continue the story.
Makima simply smiled and implied that if Power
was so inclined to settle her score with the
hard-to-destroy reptile, Public Safety could
get in contact with the Foundation and have
her on flight to Site 19 by that evening.
Power suddenly realized that she came down
with a terrible case of whatever crippling
disease would be a sufficient excuse for her
not to do that to this moment.
Makima nodded and encouraged her subordinates
to return to work.
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go check out “Rick and Morty More Powerful
Than SCP Foundation?
Mad Scientist Battle!” and “SCP-096 VS
Siren Head” for more crazy crossovers!